well good evening everyone thank you so
much
for joining us i want to say a big thank
you to our guests tonight
and obviously a big thank you to those
of you who are
uh watching us for the live stream
tonight's discussion is the second in
actually a series of events and this is
the final
discussion actually the series of online
events that
were be proudly co-hosted between design
anthology
and the design singapore council as part
of
the visions of the future exhibition so
tonight's talk
is entitled a new design manifesto for
the future
and i'm susie from design anthology and
i'll be hosting the talk
and joining me are actually six
designers who hopefully you can see
um we have christine lou
and florian wiggins of studio florine
and christine
christine is dialing in from hong kong
and florian's
dialing in from frankfurt and the two of
them
are based obviously between hong kong
and germany but
were working internationally before
covert and
their work is very much an intersection
between craft
culture and technology
uh joining us from seoul this evening
is uh jihi moon and hayen choi
of studio new tab 22
thanks for joining us so the two of them
recently
graduated from the royal college of art
in london
and are already gaining quite a bit of
recognition for their work
which focuses on natural materials
or new and overlooked materials so thank
you for joining us from seoul
and last but not least we have two
emerging designers from singapore whose
work was part of
visions of the future exhibition
i can see inchuan next to me on the left
i don't know how she's appearing on the
screen to everybody else but inchwon
is a multi-disciplinary designer who
graduated from the design academy in
hindh
eindhoven and whose work seeks to revive
the joy
of making what we use and her mass
production of happiness which is part of
the visions of the future exhibition
was first exhibited during dutch design
week
in 2018. and cheryl tang
is an industrial designer also based in
singapore
who dwells in the wonders of materiality
and tactile
experimentation and who's who approaches
fashion with an inquisitive mind and is
a meticulous designer maker
so thank you to you all for joining me
tonight we have quite an international
panel
uh i want to just say quickly to the
audience for anyone who's dialing in and
watching
tonight live we have the ability to do a
bit of q a so i have obviously
a long list of questions that i i want
to ask each of our
panel members and but there will be an
opportunity for the audience to answer
questions or ask questions and for each
of the panelists
to answer as well so please type those
in and we'll have an
opportunity to respond to questions at
the very end
so without further ado my first question
and i would love for each of you to
respond to this if you could
is given the title of tonight's talk
uh is what role do you see design
playing in the survival of humankind
on our planet a bit of a serious
question to start with
who would like to respond to that first
can we say that first please yeah
[Music]
thank you i think um so
we all designers and as i'm also
designers i think
we are ought to have to design focused
on thinking of the sustainability
with our concentration and interest
in our environmental issues and with the
concentrated research based on your
interest
i think designers can better
to choose a sustainable or environment
friendly materials
or developing it i think traditionally
designers used to design some products
based on the thinking or
plan that how we are going to
manufacture
efficiently or effectively in the
factories
however things are having changed a lot
and there are more than that
now so now i think we have to really
consider
and observe if there is any other option
rather than choosing
um just like plastic in the factories we
have to choose
like alternative materials or
sustainable materials or
we if there is another sustainable way
of making or manufacturing in that
process
i think by doing so the design can be
play a role
after having a good effect on our planet
uh christine i can see you nodding your
head would you um
do you want to add anything to that yeah
i mean
i'm following on that attractive thought
i agree and
i think throughout humankind we have
been
you know creating and adapting to
different changes
for a long time now and especially now
in 2021 i think that's no different
and i would say specifically from a
design perspective
we have been trained to you know think
creatively out of the box
and ask maybe different questions and
i think that's something that's really
important to flow and i
such as challenging you know how do
young designers today
question how things are produced and
made and
also as consumers how do we choose
wisely and
what we consume yeah um
would you like to add to that maybe yeah
um
so i think um as
designers what we have as a mission
especially in our studio is we try to
inspire
um while we of course see maybe one of
our
projects might not you know get rid of
all
the waste material in all of hong kong
for example but we hope to inspire a
larger conversation
and i think as much as is about what we
do it's
also about what we shouldn't do i mean
design
is just as much as it can be a
sustainable
industry it's also a very wasteful
industry
about trading over stock and things so
it's really about okay
how can we um create
like make smart decisions about what we
do and what we don't do
[Music]
yeah uh in schwann or cheryl would you
like to add to that and perhaps you know
obviously use your work
um as a context to your answer
uh cheryl i think you might actually be
on mute sorry do you want to unmute
yourself first
sorry it's okay
how would you like to respond are you
sure you wanna
i'm sure you can go first okay
okay um i think i agree largely with
um what um all the other designers have
mentioned so far
and i do think that a huge aspect about
design is
is proposing alternative realities
alternate realities
um what could be and in design we're
always looking
forward towards the future and
uh so proposing all these alternate
realities is kind of in a way
um guiding uh proposing different
alternatives for people to start living
to
to move towards in the future and also
it's about education
giving hope and inspiring and i think
through a design
we should be able to um help
the mankind survive better in a way so
that we don't bring ourselves to
uh doom or like this other dystopian
well yeah yeah let's keep our fingers
crossed right
would you like to add to that yeah i
think on top
of that like being like design being a
communication
or storytelling tool i think
the way we respond to these like issues
like sustainability can also be
less serious sometimes it's not always
limited to
being very serious and we can also
reflect in a more
like fun and humorous way also like a
light-hearted
way that's probably a better way to
engage with the general public would you
agree
yeah i i think so although i feel like
um design most of the times and when we
design
people are very um attracted to
beautiful or like good aesthetics and i
think it's very natural
and i think maybe humor is just like
a final one of the ways to like finally
add something an extra ingredient that
you add on top
um yeah i agree
um so each of you uh you know i was
going to say
you know the next generation you're
certainly a lot younger than i am
as you know a new or a young or an
emerging generation of designers
i would love to hear your thoughts on
you know what you think perhaps
might be some of the greatest challenges
you know i think each of you have
touched on
sustainability or the environment in
some way
as a response to the first question
i wonder if there are any other
challenges or issues that you think
um you know are urgently needing to be
addressed and
what role design can play in addressing
those issues
did any of you wanted to add to that
perhaps
any other challenges that uh urgently
need addressing other than the climate
crisis
which is a pretty big i one
maybe i can start with that um so
with our work we always try to engage
conversations
and i think what um
social media or the media in general has
us unable to do
to really expand this conversation about
uh you know talking to all these people
we
probably would never had had the chance
to if it wasn't for
let's say instagram facebook etc but
also what i think what is the problem
also with these
uh mediums is that you
too idly swipe by you look at it and you
say yeah that's a great point but
i think there's so much overload of
information
uh also happening in and around design
that like
oh that you potentially can't fully
engage and then maybe
not really look at the full issues and i
think
while these mediums can help us they
might also like you know
uh make us potentially a bit more too
passive saying that
okay a like is you know helping to clean
the oceans everything
maybe it does i mean maybe algorithms no
more than me
um but i think it's
maybe seeing okay there's a lot being
done but i think there's
always more than what we think what we
should try to see that we can inspire
more people to engage in this practice
as well rather than
you know okay there's a lot being done
already i think i can do
other things um yeah i think social
media
is um you know it's obviously
an amazing tool and an amazing medium
but you know i think you're right that
there is this sort of habit perhaps
of uh you know yeah people swiping quite
quickly through content and not having
the ability to really
absorb information and uh
yeah we're all a little overloaded
sometimes with with everything that's
out there you know there's
um waves of information
so it's a really good point uh did
anyone else uh
want to add anything to perhaps what
florian
said are there any other issues that you
can see
that urgently need addressing
if i may yeah cheryl please yeah i just
think that um
even though people are aware of the the
the needs
like the to um climate change all these
global issues
but people are not really reflecting on
their actions they're
somehow like we're we have a rapid pace
in our society
and there is somehow a very high demand
for material objects
and as compared to the past especially
um perhaps because
fabricating manufacturing technology has
become better
things are made faster so um it's not
just fast fashion it's not just for the
fashion industry but also for the
products
um in the product industry things are
made to
not be as long lasting as it used to be
and so we we tend to buy a lot but we
don't necessarily um use them for a long
time we
we throw we throw and we change our
things uh as we realize that we're
drowning in all our impulsive buys
and so i think uh yeah so i think um
design really needs to it's not just
about um
education it's also about uh influencing
behavior buyer behavior
so that um people are more not just
not just beyond awareness like how else
can we perhaps
invite them to take action and to be
part of this
movement if i may see yeah i think
that's a really great point i might come
back to that
and and dig a little bit deeper after a
couple of questions but i think yeah
that's
really interesting uh i i might actually
move on to the next question and i have
actually
um a few of you talk about
a bit more about sustainability and
sustainable practices
um but maybe in the context of of recent
work and maybe inch one if you wouldn't
mind
starting um with the product that you
created which actually i think i believe
you started working on before the
visions of the future exhibition is that
correct and before covert
miraculously um but obviously it has you
know quite a very strong
uh sustainable aspect to to what it is
do you want to try and describe a little
bit about
what what it is yeah
uh so my project is called mass
production of happiness
and it is uh touching on sustainability
in terms of like
the amount of waste that soap bottles
actually create
for our environment and i think as a
designer it was
also to be honest quite difficult to
enter and actually talk about
sustainability because
even for although like cheryl said that
a lot of people
although like everyone knows the urgency
of like climate change
etc but then like not many people are
really reflecting but i always feel like
sustainability
is a very scary word to approach and
such a big topic
so even as a designer myself i was very
worried to actually go into it
and then so what i actually tried to do
is to try
from a very like small action and a
small object which is the soap
bottle that we interact with every day
so mass production of happiness is
actually a machine a soap machine that's
made in glass
to produce soap with natural materials
at home and is actually to envision
an alternative future with no more
plastic packaging but only little
machines that add so making to our daily
cleansing rituals so there are a few key
materials that goes into the machine
which is
aloe vera water and soap nuts so soap
nuts is actually the original source of
foam which is from the ingredient called
the saponins
so that is actually what makes our soap
foam foam up
so what i'm trying to create here is
like to achieve a balance between like
the user
and like our environment so i feel like
most of the times when
you talk to someone about sustainability
they feel like if i do
something for sustainability i also lose
something
i lose like a certain type of
convenience like so what can i gain from
it
so the whole idea is that like
in the um if you buy actually a soap
bottle
there's a lot of unknown ingredients in
there that you're not aware of
but then what you gain from using your
making your own soap is that you have
control and can actually be completely
natural and organic
and then at the same time when you're
cleansing yourself you're also
indirectly cleansing the environment
and yeah so with a joint effort from
everyone we hope to like achieve like a
mass production of happiness
even though this soap production is like
at home on your own on a very small
scale
it's also a very beautiful contraption
as well i might add
i might actually skip to um hey
and see here because i think you know
the the recent project or perhaps the
material that you created
has a very strong aspect of
sustainability to it and i would love to
have you talk a little bit about what
that is this
uh you know really interesting material
innovation
can you talk about that thank you for
introducing
our project and um recently we have been
developing system project
when we started this project we started
in the college royal college walton
london
we both were very interested in how to
utilize the waste
or some discarded materials bring into
our real daily life so at the starting
point we both were very
exciting about how we using the seafood
waste
so it was kind of big like subject but
we were researching a lot and and
especially we found out
after that um seven million tons of
seashells actually are generating in the
world
and those are throwing away even some of
them are recycled
or used as a fertilizer most of them are
abandoned and goes to landfills
that's what we found and why we are
doing research
deeply we found out that the shells are
actually
um contains 90 percent of caution
carbonate
which is a main contributor of the
making concrete
that's why we are that's how we start to
do
this project at the initial part yeah
and and so on and then kept going this
we are keep going this project and we
carried out
the projects for more than like a year
just for finding out what kind of
materials to be combined
the waste metal waste shells together
so it can be more strong and solid
useful material to be used for the
people
in general yeah so there are a lot of
struggles and researches and tasks has
been going
in uh for a year more than a year
actually
and then yeah and then we have the kind
of huge
ego to to further sustainability
it was quite challenging for us but
especially we spend our so
most of time and effort on the process
to make
because we wanted to somehow minimize
the energy consumption
where even though we are making the
sustainable materials
originally or traditionally actually sea
shells if you put one more than 1 000
degree
of the high hit energy it uh it can be
transformed
into the actual source of concrete uh
as a as you heard might be like tabby
concrete in italy
we use in ancient times but however as i
mentioned
we wanted to reduce somehow those um
process to not generating the carbon
footprint
or harming environments so therefore
instead of
using high heat energy we had we have
tested more than 100 times
of the what to 200 times
200 types of recipes to develop the
system
yeah thus we started the system and the
end of
it and we are now making the some wall
panels or decoration tiles or products
for using a system
to be used in the reality that was
our very cool
in some ways actually when i saw the
product it reminded me a little bit of
uh something that florian and christine
did
recently in hong kong but design trusts
critically handmade so yeah you have
these these bricks
or kind of structural elements
is that right yeah yes
[Music]
right so florian and christine you
created
um well i saw a brick on at an
exhibition in hong kong
there were probably more than one um do
you want to talk a little bit about that
project that was shown
during the design trust exhibition and
anything
any other projects that you've worked on
where sustainability has been
you know part of the work
well i would say like for our studio
sustainability
is a big part of our design research
having been based in hong kong for the
past three years
part of our main focus is looking at
local waste materials from
plastics to glass to construction waste
so with the project you just talked
about hong kong berg
that was a i guess initiative started by
design trust which is
a local ngo based here in hong kong that
supports creative projects and
we're asked to create something in the
midst of mid-19
something that could be done like at our
home
and something small scale and for flow
and i
we were just walking around and we
noticed whether it's from
you know the economy and things like
that we found a lot of construction
waste
and we were curious how we could utilize
that as
kind of to create an object that's also
like symbolic
and has a meaning to yeah symbolize this
time that we are
in now and we decided well one of the
techniques that we have been working on
as a design studio is just
creating different torozzo surfaces
whether in tiles or breaks
and we decided to do a brick which was
just like a nice symbol
for finding the construction waste and
kind of rebuilding it
into a object that could be used to
rebuild new features so we wanted to
kind of create this like positive
message from our final outcome
and then we ended up doing a laser
engraving of just the words hong kong
and chinese on
yeah it's great i i feel like you know
the two those two projects remind me of
each other in some ways
did you want to add anything to that
florine
um i mean probably if we talk about
recent projects i mean we've been
working out together for about
three and a half four years now and i
think every single project had some sort
of sustainability aspect
in it uh whether it's waste materials or
innovative like simply natural materials
i think yeah adding to the hong kong
brick i think
it was just like really interesting like
in a time where the city is going
through so much change it's like really
about okay how can we use this
old wasteful stuff and uh
rebuild ourselves a new future with that
so i think
what we tried is really creating an
aspect of hope or at least
representative
of this object and there were
multiple and i think in the end there
was 151 to be exact
of these bricks wow that are in
existence yeah
amazing and cheryl i know the project
that you had
on show um during visions of the future
was
you know very focused on material
innovation
um but you know sustainability something
that you would say is a big part of your
practice as a designer
as well i think foster is a
consideration that is
um constantly um on my mind uh i think
part of the reason why i got really
excited with this when i
when i was doing my project was because
i thought ed was such a
readily available resource we are
constantly surrounded by it
and so what can we how can we utilize it
or use it meaningfully
um and and i found out that actually
it's rather versatile and
um you can use it for furniture you can
use it for
not just clothing and also even for
spaces in terms of like even like sound
um sound proofing or like providing
insulation
so things like that and also um
yeah and uh i think another thing it's
about
um i think perhaps because coming from a
local like a singaporean perspective
is that uh like if we travel to
countries of different
um climb different temperatures
different climates uh we don't need we
don't need two jackets
if we want to go somewhere with uh 16
degree and somewhere with uh maybe
three degrees i was thinking about how
might we be able to because mine is
deflated it's still ejected but it's
just less insulating
and then when it's inflated um it's it's
even more insulating and even and the
same applies for the chair
um you don't need a wingback chair
specifically just for the winter seasons
you can just have
one that's for the summer without the
fabric and one with the fabric or
clothing for the chair
for um the winter the colder climates
yeah
so i think that in a way yeah that's how
i see
the sustainability aspect in my world
yeah
i think i need one of those jackets for
melbourne's winter
um so you know i think you know there's
no
doubt that we're living in the future or
so we keep being told that we're living
in the future but you know i wanted to
actually ask each of you
whether you think perhaps that there is
an element of society or the way that we
live
that may need to actually look to the
past for our survival and you know
whether that may be
things like waste reduction and
frugality i think you know when i
talk of frugality i think of my
grandparents they were
you know very aware of what they
consumed and how much money they spent
but because of that there was far less
waste
you know things like adaptive reuse of
buildings
but i'm also thinking about exploring
ancient or even indigenous techniques or
crafts
or materials or skills and i wanted to
hear your thoughts on that whether you
think that perhaps looking backwards
may actually help us
and maybe you know guide our way forward
out of covert and maybe out of the
climate crisis
would any of you like to respond to that
um i mean i mean i can start uh
so what our studio does is often
i mean not for every single project but
it's about really looking at
heritage crafts of a spectacular place
for the past three years now that has
been hong kong
so we've been looking at for example
neon light makers or ceramicists
or um really different types of artisans
and uh or fishermen as well
um and what we try to do is
okay here we have these uh
heritage crafts that really can are able
to transfer
a message within the local society that
mean something to them and while we
think it's not we shouldn't just you
know
redo the old things you know there's
potentially a reason why they are not
that relevant anymore so what we try in
our project is to like see how we can
just combine sustainable
um ideas and values into these crafts
and by combining them
maybe help to really
like traverse between cultures ages
and really see that there's a common
connection ground where lots of people
can
talk about and i think that's where
it's really helpful because i mean
our past is our culture so really it's
like okay how
can we use our culture and design to
help promote
sustainable living i think that's a big
aspect of our studio
um hayen and jihi do you have anything
to
add to that perhaps from a korean
perspective
well green context only in the pandomic
situation
after we moved to south korea actually
we found out that
there are actually lots of thinkers
designers or
um craft moloka makers
are actually hidden under the surface i
think
and if design how somehow
can generate a process which way of the
door
bring those people onto the top of the
surface so that
they can somehow contribute the local
making system
in that way i was like reminding of the
maker
movement so i think it might be a good
solution
to bring all these people together and
mingles those people like
people in general or skilled craft
people or
and and even educators so that they can
make their own
like products locally at the same time
we can like
somehow preserving or regenerating our
korean or in the other country's local
craft skills and ideas
i think um
uh cheryl or inshwan do you have
anything that you'd like to
add to those comments
no um
i don't i'm not sure if we really have
to go back
to the past to survive the future but i
think we're
definitely very inspired by like many
practices
in the past like of course also from the
indigenous
times so uh maybe just
an example that i also found out like
later in the
in my project that actually like soap
nuts the main ingredients that i was
using in the machine itself
is actually a traditional
ingredient that is being used by native
indians
and it's always it's always been like a
natural insecticide or like treatment
for skin condition like eczema so i
think
then it was only um
through looking at all these uh
information from history and all these
things that
finally helped me to decide that oh i
think this is the way to go
and this is the exact ingredient that
i'm looking for so
i think in that way it's very inspiring
as well
yeah that's really interesting i think
something else that you know has been
perhaps highlighted during covert and
the pandemic
is perhaps supply chain issues
you know i think what we've realized is
that perhaps countries that don't
actually make things anymore
uh have had supply chains disrupted
uh and you know the flow of
products has been slowed down or stopped
in some cases and
i'm curious to know what you all think
about
what we what else we can do to help
preserve
craft and cultural identity
through design um but without it being
you know inward looking i think we're
living in a very polarized uh
world politically and so without it
being
adding to those arguments about
nationality and culture how can
how can we preserve cultural tradition
and identity through craft and through
design without it being
inward looking how can we kind of you
know
do that and kind of add to a global um
design community i don't know if
christine and florian you want to add to
that because i know that craft tradition
and
and the preservation of that is you know
a big part of what you do
yeah i answer a big question but i would
say
to address the first part of the
question i do think
supply chain is probably the hardest
thing to
address as we've seen globally
and i think in terms of how we produce
things
that's definitely a big question
especially for designers as well
and i think from what we've seen it's
important
when you know we can't import things
anymore
that there's this like going back to
self-reliance and how to make things
and as an american there was like
a shortage of masks and i knew that a
lot of my friends and family had to
just you know bring bring out the sewing
kit
and they were like forced to just like
make masks and
i think it was kind of a i guess the
silver lining was that it
definitely brought people together and
brought communities together
and there was like an example there was
like a local
shop that actually sold furniture but
they used their like leftover
upholstery fabrics to make masks for
the community so i think that was
definitely
a nice thing for people to see that um
when
we're forced to be self-reliant that
when many
minds come together that we're able to
you know still achieve
although it's not the way that we're
used to
and i think rather than seeing that as
wanting to
become isolated or like not relying on
our modern kind of global network i
think it's just like
encouraging us to see yeah how we
consume and
what's like the right balance between
like supporting local businesses
while still staying relevant and modern
and being able to have access to things
around the world
so although i don't think that would
answer i think yeah
um as next steps i think we have to like
be forced to
address yeah like what's the right
balance for us as
global consumers yeah i think that's a
really great point
um ing shawn and cheryl do you have
anything to add to that because you know
singapore
doesn't have a sort of traditional
manufacturing industry
as such like other countries do did you
find there were any
disruptions perhaps to material supply
did it you know the pandemic affect your
practice
in that way over the last year
no that's good to hear did you want to
add anything cheryl or
uh yeah i don't think it has affected
me very much but i do think that um one
way design can
help to preserve crafts well while um
um what's that what's that um
yeah i mean linking to the question
sorry i forgot the term that you used
uh i think one way is to um
to uh involve the community to
uh to have different stakeholders
because then
they can provide uh multiple
perspectives and
uh so that you don't become too inward
looking
and you don't um become too focused on
just one thing
yeah so that's that's probably my take
on that yeah
and and what about you oh sorry florian
did you want to add
yeah i think talking like um cheryl
mentioned community i think
it's really important like talking about
globalism and locality is like it's
really important to
uh design with and for the local
community and
really with the question with what is
the aim of your design is your aim of
the design
to you know um like change the ways we
think locally or completely globally so
i think as a studio we
really think we design for hong kong
and for all people surrounding in the
area
while trying to give out the message of
the sustainability
to the global uh world if you want to
call it that
and the really question does always have
the physical design object have to be
the export products like really is it
about you know
physical supply chain of whether it's
just you know
um having a message and that's the
supplied things that you send out to the
global
world rather than the physical objects
yeah that's a really good point actually
and i think you know obviously an event
like tonight uh who knows what the you
know
this experience of of the pandemic would
have been like without
zoom and other platforms that we're
obviously utilizing
maybe too much at the moment but as you
say
we can use that to communicate tools and
ideas
and um you know further discussion which
you know maybe is just as important as
exporting physical products
i wanted to ask um hayen and jiahi did
you
have any you know issues during
covert with a supply chain or any of
those kinds of things that you wanted to
add to that conversation perhaps
um well um
actually um well
in the co in the after i we moved in
south korea we couldn't find any like
huge issue regarding the pandemic
situation
or the manufacturer is ongoing yeah
stealing gold yes you're on goal
amazingly yeah that's amazing yeah
the country is so attached with china
and they are usually manufacturers and
plastic
and everything so many people are not
that much aware
about the stopping the manufacturing
system
and they are not that much get affected
but
we are much more like focusing like
people are actually losing their job
from
like because they have small businesses
they don't people don't go out
anymore and those are really
heartbreaking
somehow yeah more that kind of problem
we have i know yeah i think that's
definitely across the board but
you know given that the the subject of
tonight's talk which is a new
design manifesto for the future which i
hope hints at it's something that's a
bit more optimistic and and
forward-looking you know we've
i think everyone around the world has
certainly experienced
challenges and hopefully not all of them
negative
so i wanted to end on a final question
before we we go
to the audience and see if they have
questions and and that is
about hope and optimism because i i hope
that um that all of us or many of us
have
actually experienced some positivity um
from covert and even if it is just more
moments of
being able to reflect and think about
you know what we're consuming or what
we're designing what we're making
and so yeah i wanted to ask you about
what you think the role
of hope and optimism is in
you know a new design manifesto how
important is that
um and and you know if you have any
uplifting stories or exciting news that
you want to share it would be really
nice to end the conversation
on a positive note
who would like to florian
uh
i mean you feel optimistic about you
know the rest of this year and going
forward maybe that's a better way to
start the question
um i mean personally as a studio what i
think is really optimistic for us so
normally we would be working
four five six i don't know how many
projects a year
and i mean each project of course would
only get so much attention as well
and then really this year or last year
the
main part or the only project we really
worked on as a studio was the hong kong
break
and of course giving us so much more
time with
a specific objective specific project
and
i think also the platform the design
tester worked on like um
it helped us really to get so many more
conversations
uh around this object rather than you
know we have it
i don't know like half a year we do the
project we exhibited for another half a
year or so and that's sort of it
and i think here the conversation is
spreading wide and it's free
also like we talking with others that
like
what's the continuation i mean like of
this specific object and i think
that is like this slowing down
focusing on maybe less
i think it's a different way of working
of course
like one versus six projects a year um
but uh yeah i think there's a certain
sense that
maybe like i mean overall probably the
world needs a bit slowing down
and i think maybe to pandemic
can help us to not return to the
previous novel but to a new normal where
it's a little bit slow and i think that
gives me personally some optimism yeah
about
design that's good to hear
uh what about you christine do you echo
those sentiments do you have anything to
add
yeah um i guess to conclude like
um as mentioned by fellow designers here
you know the beauty of design is
that we can bring you know different
kind of aspects of awareness into our
lives through
creating objects whether it can be
serious but it can also
be you know beautiful and humorous and
joyful
and i think that's the beauty of you
know creativity and it's being designers
is that there's
kind of infinite ways that you can um
channel like your message or what you're
trying to share
and i think that's something that both
flo and i really enjoy
and i think as the world is coming back
to
or just kind of recovering from you know
last year
i think there is a lot of hope and
optimism or just like this
ambition to like build things better and
or at least personally i think for our
studio and
as young designers i think we want to
challenge the way that things are made
and the way
we see consumption and how we can
build kind of a better for rebuild a
better foundation
for ourselves that's really great to
hear
and hayen and do you hear you know what
would you like to add to that you know
are you feeling hopeful and optimistic
about
the future and and what you can
contribute to a world
that is yeah the new normal well
contributing the world is kind of big
yeah okay let's take korea to start with
it's good to all not only the designers
people um just have a smooth movement
by themselves even though it's like
small things that oh i'm not gonna
use any of this water plastic or
i'm gonna just like um help we're gonna
help each other together we're gonna
rebuild our community together i think
that's the more like
better way to approach of the
in that subject and um i think
in that pandemic situation even though a
lot of
struggles and everybody were very hard
had a hard time but
if i say uplifting news or story
not just design it's like people are
starting
making something in their home even
though like a small
like i don't know like plaster or
something but
i think it's a good move to start like
making their value themselves
by or by helping um from the helping um
some local makers or local craft people
and i think that's a kind of good and
uplifting news
for the design society
yeah absolutely what about you cheryl
what are you hopeful and optimistic
about
why am i hopeful and optimistic as well
well are you for a start i hope you are
i
i am in general a very optimistic person
and uh i do think that hope and optimism
is very important um especially because
i think as designers if we are hopeful
and optimistic
it reflects in our works and then this
is like a ripple effect
kind of influences like um whoever who
sees our works
and i think that um it's important to be
um
hopeful and optimistic because when you
see things as a half glass full kind of
like
everything is a blessing in disguise
it's something that i live by everything
is really a blessing in disguise
uh you you look at opportunities rather
than um
whatever is um the bad stuff you don't
focus on the negative you just
try to work with the opportunities the
parameters that you have and
yeah some i'm very and i think these
parameters parameters are really
important to
to designers i i think we can all agree
and yeah so i think
i'm really optimistic about um how
we will move as a society in general um
as a design culture design movement
in general yeah that's good too so i'm
just optimistic in general
that's good to hear what about you and
chan
i think in general
i feel that i'm looking more at like
very small
things when it when we talk about
optimism so
like actually when i first heard about
the question i was thinking more of like
new design opportunities because like
i feel i'm not sure about like other
countries like
like germany korea and hong kong but
like in singapore
like most if you're entering like a
shopping mall
most of the exits are closed you're only
limited to like one
entrance and one exit and then like
the way like wayfinding has changed
the way you people like circulate within
a
space or outside the space has also
changed a lot
so then i feel like when we're forced to
like
into this kind of situation then you
start to have a lot of new ideas and i
start wondering if
architects and designers are also
using this kind of behavior to like
really design new buildings like
is this part of a consideration in the
future
and also what i think was very positive
in singapore was that
during the like what we call the circuit
breaker like a semi lockdown
a lot of businesses just emerged
like little food businesses because we
could only depend on technology
and then i feel like everyone was just
like forced to stay at home and there's
a lot of new ideas start like popping up
just because we had the moment
at home with a family or at the moment
with yourself but
i feel like besides designers like
everyone probably have like new ideas
and like
uh super excited about them yeah
yeah absolutely i i heard at one point
that you could get a cocktail delivered
to your door in singapore
with a bar man to mix it for you that
was that was the level of technology i
was so impressed
um so i think we're coming to an end of
the time that we have but
i think we actually maybe have time for
one audience question
um and that is perhaps if any of you
want to
[Music]
talk about anything that you're working
on at the moment so sort of looking
forward to the future whether there's a
new technology
or a new material new product that
you're working on that you're excited
about
want to end on an optimistic note if
anyone wants to share something that
is new that you're able to talk about
we'd love to hear about that
before we wrap up who would like
to tell us a bit about what they're
doing
florian you look like you're about to
say something
sorry i was like i mean
as i said like we've been working on
only one project for the past year but i
think
what this gave us the chance as well i
mean it obviously gave us a lot of
i wouldn't call it down time but maybe
time to reflect on and i think
this time was really what us what do we
want to explore
like what is like how can our studio
evolve
etc and i mean
we probably have plans for the next i
don't know 10 projects or 20 projects
that's how many
like ideas of different like how what
craftsmen
we want to work with or with what
technologies and i think
yeah this abundance really i think
that's i think
of possibilities i think that's
difficult going back to the
uh previous question as well that makes
us optimistic as well
like really like and
i mean particularly talking about things
practices
i don't know um maybe down
don't forget about our research our
upcoming research project
you have to tell us questions we'll have
one thing that we are
or another thing we are working on it's
just um
an upcoming project it's called tactile
technology
and essentially yeah it's
[Laughter]
well to stay in a nutshell because we
do hope to exhibit it soon but this
research
involves um we've been working with 3d
knitting technology
so it's kind of a more sustainable way
of making because
rather than having off cuts it's
basically knit to shape
and we're creating a series of
textile light objects that are also
interactive
due to we're integrating these
conductive
threads onto the knitted textile
so essentially these light pieces will
be touch based and it'll have this more
interactive
light design involved so yes
thanks to
you we look forward to seeing that um
in schwein and sheryl do you have
anything that's coming up that you're
able to talk about anything or even just
that you're excited
about for the coming year with your
practices
for me like mass production of happiness
was
uh actually made to be like a whole
series of
glass vessels so each machine is
supposed to work with
only the recipe itself so
like there are actually a few recipes
that i was looking at previously hoping
to still
like build some machines from it and
also i do have another project that is
currently on pause due to like
limitation of producing locally so
i think that's maybe a bad move
i should try to also learn to produce
locally
[Laughter]
well we can look forward to seeing that
when it happens what about you cheryl
anything you're able to talk about
um not at the moment for me yeah
okay well we look forward to seeing what
comes next anyway
um and what about you hayne and is there
anything
new from you that you can talk about
we are going to keep going for the
system project
to be used widely and also at the same
time
we're watching for going more locally
and so as we as far as we can just
right here and basically we are finding
some
i think it's something like similar
project with the fluorine
right yeah we are finding some locker
waist and
material like concrete ways and metals
crabs or
some even some wood so i think
bringing some people and make them
participate can be
um a huge project at the same time it
would be fun
so we are going to more like locally
and going to narrow down the project
amazing well i i want to say thank you
again to all of you for your time this
evening it's been so interesting
chatting with you and hearing about
what's coming up you've definitely left
me
feeling very optimistic which is nice
after such a challenging year for
everybody
i wish you all the very best stay safe
and well
and uh and yeah we look forward to
seeing what comes next from each of you
so thank you and and good night